if you see white people waiting on the
bus stop they're not mad they're not
angry
buses three hours late
I hope the bus driver is okay
if you see a [__] sitting on the bus
stop we are mad at a [__] it
ain't got [__] to do with the Bucks we
just sitting there
[Applause]
get mad at [__] that's driving
[__] atheist now got out of
hand
now they want to tell us what the [__]
we believe I mean you believe in God so
that means you don't believe in science
what the [__] is you talking about
I prayed to God before every science
test I don't know what the [__] you
talking about
Jesus was in my class you son of them
atheists [__] up atheist here my whole
story hear what I believe then he gonna
tell me nah that don't make no [__]
sense at all okay well tell me your [__]
this [__] is that two [__]
atoms just came the [__] together
just came together out of nowhere banged
together and made this whole perfect
Earth
[__] out of here
you stupid enough to believe that [__]
boy [__] after this show go outside to
the parking lot and bang on your car
till it becomes a better car
you just out there
[Applause]
what the
[__] just gotta make your own decisions
they tell you you should not smoke
cigarettes
because it will stunt your growth
and when you're a kid they tell you
drink all your milk
[Music]
vegetables
so that you can grow up big and strong
and I remember as a child
drinking milk every day just bring a cow
in and let me get up under him and drink
some fresh milk so I can be big and
strong
broccoli give me all the broccoli and
greens and spinach
let me show y'all some [__] y'all not
gonna believe
what my mother and father please stand
up in the audience right now
I'm looking around
Now look up there at my pants up at the
top
my daddy five and my mama five three
what the [__] was I drinking milk from
snacks
I could have been eating lemon heads and
baked beans all day
[Applause]
y'all don't know it ain't no fun
Cincinnati right now worried about black
and white Prejudice that ain't [__]
compared to the Prejudice of being short
an American society this is [__] you
don't know how I had to overcome ain't
no parades ain't no marches Justin
Jackson don't show up
all the [__] y'all take for granted like
that little thing your mama put by the
door to mark your size every year we
just had one dark ass line
forget about it on the top of it just
one talk
[Applause]
then you grow up and be the same size
you got to be a pimp
you just can't be no regular [__] this
size simple enough
go to an amusement park
truck Kings Island I don't give a [__]
I'm a grown ass man what do you mean I
can't ride this goddamn ride
grown ass man
spent a hundred dollars I gotta ride in
a teacup with little kids this is
[__] when we get out this
[__] I am gonna kick your
[__] ass
thank you
I'm enjoying my [__] life
that's all I'm saying I advise you to do
the same do [__] that make you happy go
out and get you some white friends get
you some white [__] friends you
ain't gotta sleep with them but you
gonna need them [__] if you go
to jail and call your [__] friends
these [__] will interrogate you
more than the goddamn police did they
have your ass on the phone where the
[__] was you at
what the [__] was you doing why the [__]
you ain't call me not your white friends
that [__] will be there by the
time you hang up the phone and they'll
be madder than you just what the [__]
did he do
murder murdered huh look I [__] known
him for two weeks he wouldn't [__] do
something like that
gotta love white people I don't give a
[__] what you say white people are
friendly you can call them [__]
up at three o'clock in the morning with
the wrong number and they won't even be
mad at you hello
no I'm sorry no Shaquita here
well what number did you dial
no it's a nine not a seven
we'll try it if it doesn't work call me
back we'll figure this thing out
[Applause]
what kind of little white people
it's thanks to white people we know
anything about wild animals you realize
that [__] have never in the history of
[__] them discovering a wild animal
not one not a wild pit bull nothing
cause we too cautious [__] don't
discover [__] we don't get close enough
to discover [__] take no chances that
what [__] is that a Rottweiler or a
bear [__] go go no go [__] that goal
[Applause]
white people though let me say this
y'all need some [__] friends get you
some [__] friends just don't ever ever
call them your [__] friends don't ever
got a [__] the relationship up there's
my [__] friend
you guys say it all the time what
eat your [__] friends so they can tell
you when [__] is not appropriate
first of all white people please stop
putting them little blue leashes on your
children please stop stop doing that
that is only entertainment for [__]
that's all that is we be excited then
the [__] look at them
that's why white kids grow up and kill
everybody in the goddamn school because
you don't treating them like a German
Shepherd ever since they were three
they'd be in the store like
and even though he's my friend these
[__] still [__]
these [__] got enough money to
be whatever the [__] he wanna be his
whole life and what the [__] does this
[__] want to be a goddamn Sheriff you
gave me no goddamn Sheriff shot you are
18 foot 6 foot 12 and then I don't [__]
you can't even go undercoverness do you
have any drugs no Shaq
that's your [__] ass
you a dumb [__] [__] if you let
Shaq pull you out the car you could
could you make a free throw
then I'm not getting out there and I'm
just not gonna do it
[Applause]
if you want that [__] not to shoot you
you got to dress up like a basket
we can't shoot them he can't shoot masks
whole world is [__] crazy you don't
know what to trust you can [__] around
and stay away from gang bangers and Drug
deals and still get killed by a squirrel
you gotta try to act like it wasn't the
squirrel oh [__] [__] don't tell my mom
it was a squirrel [__] don't tell my
mama it was a squirrel tell that [__]
shot me with two small bullets in the
neck
he won the 22 it was at 11. [__] shot
me with an 11.
oh we losing a lot of gangster [__] we
lost James Brown God damn it give it up
for The Godfather that [__] was
the [__]
we don't know none of his lyrics and
that [__] was the [__] we still
know the [__] Jay was saying
yes James yes
losing a lot of games today we lost one
of the biggest gangsters in the whole
world just recently goddamn crocodile
hunter is gone children he's gone
that my [__] y'all that [__] was
the [__]
crocodile hunter was the [__]
he wasn't scared of [__] if you think he
ain't gangster go to your neighbor house
and jump on their Rottweilers and see
how that worked out for you
that white boy was a [__] because he
wasn't mean or nasty or nothing he was
friendly and informational
oh that's a beauty right there Mike
all right I've got her in my sights now
wait for it wait boy what
[Applause]
she's riding in a bloody death roll on
me did you say I try to rule
[__] you gonna kill that [__]
and just to show you how haters be on
you this [__] didn't even get
killed by a crocodile he got killed by a
punk [__] ass Stingray ain't that some
[__]
he wasn't even a stingray Hunter
I was talking [__] the next day just I
knew something bad was gonna happen to
him [__] I knew it nah he wrestled my
uncle down on national TV [__] made a
belt where my Spanish people at where
the Spanish people we got to thank all
17 of y'all for coming we appreciate
that
I know most of you [__] rolled
together y'all [__] are
efficient
you ever seen them come to a club it'd
be 39 of them [__] in the same
car
[Applause]
I missed that is a forward Focus how
many [__] is in there
[Applause]
but you need your Spanish friends
don't nobody party like them
[__] nobody in the world party
like them [__] cause they don't
need [__] that [__] need they don't
need invitations or streamers or
balloons or nothing your [__]
only need a front yard as a
[__] Corona and them
[__]
[__] can't even go to their party
because they don't never end
[__] you have a party last three and a
half [__] months just got
[__] in their hostage
[Applause]
foreign
Spanish people you got to get you some
[__] friends too so they can tell you
when [__] is not appropriate we are
tired of going to the laundromat to see
you in there your baby girl is all of
seven years old this [__] has on a
wedding dress and soccer shoes what
what is he marrying bleach
[Applause]
all I'm saying Spanish people is if you
are pushing a stroller through the mall
and your child's feet can touch the
ground out the stroller let little essay
walk then
this [__] 13 goddamn years old a
cigarette and a sidekick push it faster
and say
it ain't that it ain't like [__] got
it all down pat when it come to raising
kids we all got problems we just got
different problems it would seem like
white people are a little bit too
lenient on their children and [__] are
a bit too harsh on ours all I'm saying
is that the white family's house you can
get time out for setting the family dog
on fire
at the [__] household you can get beat
half the death of forgetting to feed the
family dog now that's the same goddamn
dog
we just do [__] differently but white
people please take this back to your
community
please stop putting your children on
them goddamn leashes
that is just entertainment for [__] we
oh we can't wait to see that [__] in us
though we get right by the registered
little kids wake up and grow up to be 26
and kill everybody in the family because
you don't have them on a leash like a
dog they just in the toy store just I
want it I want it
and black people laughing like we got to
sit down pat we ain't no good neither
you got to stop beating your
[__] kids in a goddamn grocery
store you just said no checkout line as
soon as your baby touches the Skittles
you
just ma'am that baby is a toddler you
can't beat that
thank you
as America we too gangster
well care
America's too [__] gangster and
it'll take a whole bunch of Americans to
represent America neither they're going
to be one white woman in a field by
herself missing teeth
she can represent America just fine
they'll be right in the field just
ma'am a tornado just came and tore down
your whole city
what are you gonna do
put it on the [__] reveal
oh God damn boy here I'm a goddamn die
here
American [__]
[__] that
[__] invite me to his son's fourth
birthday party I get there me in this
goddamn babies looking each other eye to
eye and [__]
[Applause]
and his Circle had a nerve to put his
hands up like I'm gonna pick his big ass
up
put your goddamn hands down ain't nobody
picking you up [__] we the same size
you were telling me Shacks baby because
they were real big but he couldn't talk
good all he could do he could just
repeat whatever the last thing you said
I was like hey you want you want some
candy oh okay
gotta [__] away you want some chicken
I confused the [__] out that [__] I say
you want a candy off a whooping
my favorite show for two years in a
[__] row is still [__]
Swamp People that is my [__] oh my God
if you have not seen this [__] you have
not lived yet
[Music]
there's some beautiful [__] I think I
just like seeing my no uh rednecks in a
natural environment not killing
minorities I think that's what it is
I love this [__]
I watch every episode but I don't know
why because every episode is exactly
like the last goddamn episode they don't
change [__]
every episode start with a man in a boat
going nowhere fast as [__]
[Music]
I'm finding out most of the [__] I
thought was real ain't he real
I met DMX nine months ago this [__] is
two inches taller than me
I don't know why the [__] I thought that
[__] was 612 or something that [__] is
my size and he really talked like that
we're in the rest right here hell [__]
yeah
some lemon [__] why are you hollering
we in a restaurant [__]
you know that [__] wasn't [__] in
school couldn't cheat at all just hell
[__]
number seven
[__] you need to be in a special class
what the [__] is
[Applause]
I met Omarion this [__] is the king of
dancing for a [__] reason cause
all while you trying to talk to this
simple [__] he is practicing his
goddamn dance moves I'm trying to have a
conversation this is what
oh touch touch what [__] this is
I met Shaquille O'Neal I was so
[__] happy to meet that [__]
then I find out I can't be this [__]
spraying in public cause he just too
[__] tall how the [__] look
I'm trying to congratulate you on a good
game and you got your dick all on my
forehead Reggie
[Applause]
[Music]
this is [__] Nick
what is the only thing in the universe
you know the recipe
and you can't make none
[Music]
[Applause]
say it one more time cat for the people
in the back
the recipe
as soon as you get it
you can make you something
not this though
God made this and we all know the recipe
H to the two to the o
have you put an h and O together by
yourself
you just have a hope
[Applause]
and you can lead a hole to water but you
ain't gonna make none
[Music]
no no
no no no no no no no
no over here
you come to Jacksonville you ain't ready
for it I don't care where you from
you're not ready for this if you love
water you could overdose in this
[__] that Jacksonville got water
water water and water they got a creek
lakes rivers the river go the wrong way
[Applause]
if you not from here you're not you got
to be specific when you talk to your
Uber driver you can't say nothing like
I'm by the bridge
1700 bridges in this [__] you mean the
Black Bridge the yellow Bridge the blue
Bridge that's part Transformer that go
up and down they don't tell you that to
you high on the balcony what the [__] I
think I saw the bridge move
you come to Jacksonville you gonna see
[__] you don't see nowhere else
generally you can just go somewhere look
on the map and pick places out
you need a tour guide in Jacksonville
from Jacksonville to tell you where you
can and cannot go
you don't just want to be driving around
looking around
you'll see some [__] that'll scare the
[__] out of you as a [__] you
Confederate part what
what the [__] am I doing
most cities got one Hood
see how the audience laughed at that
whose [__] got one Hood
the whole map is free they tell you
don't go
not in Jacksonville
they got spots all around the map you
should look out for you
all the hoods sound like
dangerous sitcoms
tonight on another episode of Washington
Heights
something going down I'll watch it
tonight I'm pretty sure that if I know
any of the hoods in America I know
stay tuned for another edition of
Cleveland arms
it's got arms in the title I know that's
dangerous huh
[Applause]
Eureka Gardens
Eureka means surprise
and you shouldn't be here you looking
for gardens
Jacksonville do it big it ain't just
hoods they got certain streets
if you even type it in your phone
your phone will not let you make it
there
if you type in Moncrief
your phones ain't relocating
what
Jacksonville is the biggest
[__] City out there every 10
blocks is another
[__] neighborhood
if you're comfortable don't be
comfortable too long enjoy yourself
what places you go when you go to the
gas station the only thing you gotta
look at is the price of the gas
not in Jacksonville
you gotta look at some other [__]
then the price I guess you had to look
at all the surroundings of the gas
station you ever decided you didn't need
gas as bad as you thought you did
you ever got back in your car to not get
together I don't need this gas
if I can make it almost home if I just
keep on going I get a little closer to
somewhere
it's 32 [__] out there hey
selling pit bull puppies and fried
biscuits I'm not gonna do all that for
some gas I'm not cook do you cook for
your kids absolutely tell me some of the
things you could that they are proud of
like to add make some you got the best
spaghetti you got the best steak
as a father of seven with an unlimited
food budget you can make uh whatever is
necessary excuse me excuse me
just because you're a poor interviewer
doesn't mean
man you're a strong black woman
you keep interrupting the answer
everyone can hear it it sounds like you
like me a little bit it's starting to
bleed over the airway it is oh really I
want to let everybody know that Wanda
got some lipstick on right now with
enough glitter for the Fourth of July
that's right
all I'm saying is life is too short for
racism we all got [__] problems
but we can learn we can learn just
[__] just [__] [__] that
just don't try to do everything with
your white friends
don't get drunk with your white friends
can't do it can't [__] do it they
don't drink like [__] [__] we are
very consistent if a [__] drink
Hennessy that's what the [__] that [__]
drank that's what he drank Hennessy you
ain't gotta keep asking that's what they
drink on Monday Wednesday Friday his
birthday Jesus birthday Hennessy and
they don't have him to see he will take
Remy as a backup that's as far as it
goes
white people don't care what they drink
all they care about is what they said
when they was leaving the house
tonight we're getting [__] up
[Applause]
it's all the [__] they care about them
[__] you got to be careful
[__] cause they tricky white people
like to buy the drink
as a [__] we are not prepared to turn
down a free goddamn drink we don't give
a [__] what it is like this is unleaded
[__] [__] I like that
I had to find out the hard way I'm
drinking with some white people they
buying me these goddamn drinks this [__]
was delicious it was called zambuki and
I should have known that don't even
sound like no [__] a [__] should be
drinking any goddamn way sound like one
of my African cousins or some [__] but
the [__] was delicious but it was coffee
and alcohol together I was knocking them
[__] back it wasn't until I got
[__] up that I realized that maybe
maybe this is not the right combination
of [__] for a [__] to be [__] up on
cause now I'm [__] up I'm at the house
a [__] is [__] up but I can't pass
out
[__] that
[Applause]
the day started
science might have made a lot of [__]
but God made the chicken
pillow tell me God made the chicken he
did that for the world
that's how you know it's from God
what group of people don't [__] with
chicken
God made the chicken
that [__] ain't safe nowhere
every time a chicken's foot hitting the
ground somebody want to put that [__]
in Greece
in China
[Applause]
how you know God made it cause that bird
is the most delicious bird
in the whole
World Can't Fly
because God loves you
you could fly half the [__] in
here be dead right now just saying live
your [__] life you got to get
your [__] hustle understand
[__] is gonna hate you regardless get
that out of your head that fantasy world
where [__] Ain't hating on you you
gotta be grateful you need haters what
the [__] is you complaining about what
the [__] do you think a hater's job is
to [__] hate so let them
[__] do they goddamn job what
the [__] is you complaining about ladies
if you got 14 women hating on you you
need to figure out how to [__] to get
the 16 before the summer get here
[__] you mad about
fellas if you got 20 haters you need 40
of them [__] what is you
complaining about if there's any haters
in here right now that don't have nobody
that hate on feel free to hate on me sit
back there and say my hair ain't
luxurious when you know it is [__]
get second second
all right people then took over now
[__] they used to be black ain't black
no more
first thing white people took over was
rioting riots used to be some black [__]
we'll get so mad we riot y'all are
terrible at it white people we thought
y'all better than this
y'all had a million white people out
there y'all didn't do no damage at all
orange slices walking in single foul
lines y'all can't [__] [__] up cause
y'all own this [__] so y'all out there
[__] it up and cleaning it up at the
same time
white people just out there shaking
their signs hard and [__]
what are you doing using the shake
weight I'm riding the goddamn and I'm
right these are the troops they hiding
from you
I risk my life to tell you all these
truths
I'm gonna tell you another one I don't
they'll have me crucified by the morning
watch
all I gotta do is tell them to watch
this one
Wendy Williams is Bigfoot
there I said it it's out there
[Applause]
every time she's on Hiatus you see all
type of sightings
that's the truth imma tell you a
statistics gonna blow your [__] mind
there are zero [__]
making Fentanyl
look at white people
yep
you better believe it white people we
would notice if [__] was dropping dead
for nothing
[Applause]
I looked up fitting on that [__] is
beyond dangerous I said what you gotta
do to die they said
touch it
we would notice [__] dying at the
purchase
[Applause]
I'm the introduction to Tiffany haddish
in the movie School Dance
the clip for school dance has been seen
more times than the movie has that's
just a fact but but the movie girl the
the girls trip movie yes ma'am the one
with four with with three
of our greatest black actresses in it I
mean that one right right but I'm just
saying Tiffany had it ma'am you could
have had that role and everything that
happened would have happened unless you
thought you were necessary to write the
Saturday Night Live monologue
I'm a writer I only care about what you
write I don't care about what you read
everybody can read that can read
what did you think about the movie
though I I laughed from beginning to I
felt like I thought it was the right
script when I saw it in 2004. wow in
2004 wow wow I have it I'm I'm but I'm
I'm so happy for her though because
that's what it does that baby I I tear
up thinking about the break that she got
and to see her do her thing she passed
46 female black comedians that I know
personally that I put on tour who have a
hard time getting a chicken sandwich
from Chick-fil-A after they headline
seven shows at a club for 2500 a week
but people like real and that's why they
like what they like they love real
because everybody's real then so don't
trip no no tip they like wherever you at
under the sound of my voice do you have
a real card worker right do you have a
ratchet friend do you have a sister do
you have a cousin do you have a nephew
do you have a niece is they so ghetto
when did that become marketable knock it
off they like her because she want to
sleep with a white man that's why the
only thing she said was I want to give
it to Brad Pitt the only thing before
that in the movie with me is I I slept
with this white man and I got a white
baby she had a white husband for the 14
years she been doing comedy and then all
of a sudden divorced him then said he
abused her then wrote a book then said
he didn't and then now we're at Brad
Pitt so hey you can say whatever you
want she said she got a disease for JJ
don't nobody check for that
foreign